und bei uns im studio ist jetzt unser
bild chefreporter peter tiede väter wie
erklärst du dir dieses verhalten von
ursula von der leyen einfach nicht
nachgedacht und sich selbst zu wichtig
genommen also wenn man sagt man hat so
viele termine dass man da überall
hinfliegen muss dann kann man erst mal
sagen also dann mal terminplan bisschen
abspecken dann einmal kurz darüber
nachdenken das darf einem auffallen dass
man von wien nach bratislava ich bin die
strecke wird nicht mehr versetzt
gefahren das 5 wer auf die idee kommt
dazu fliegen wer da nicht merkt dass da
dass man dazu weit geht der
hat einfach nicht für 12 cent
nachgedacht und nimmt sich selbst zu
wichtig nicht mal für 11 euro
und ob sie mit der bahn fährt oder mit
dem auto fährt alles egal wie sie dahin
kommt aber dass man das nicht macht das
einfach blöd aussieht und dann das darf
man merken aber frau von der leyen hat
in ihrer karriere und so manche sache
die anderen gemerkt haben nicht selbst
gemerkt erwartest du eine reaktion von
ihr darauf
also ja
die hat man zu erwarten die darf man
auch erwarten aber ich glaube nicht dass
sie kommen die was sich in dem maße in
dem angemessenen maße wir rechnen würden
dass man sagt dass sie jetzt vor die
presse tritt und sagt heute dass man
wirklich doof da war das war dumm und
das passiert mir nicht mehr ich glaube
nicht dass es von dir zu hören peter wir
können ja den druck ein bisschen erhöhen
und holen und den jäger dazu michael
jäger ist der generalsekretär beim
europäischen steuerzahler bund herr
jäger 11 euro kostet das zugticket von
wien nach bratislava könnte frau von der
leyen eine menge steuergeld sparen ist
der dass zuzumuten
ja absolut ich
hoffe die verbindung ist gut ich sitze
witzigerweise jetzt gerade bei der
oesterreichischen nationalbank weil wenn
die veranstaltung haben die wir die
zukunft finanzieren und gestalten und
ich kenne auch nach bratislava weil ich
das schon oft genug war es ist nicht
darstellbar es ist eine ökologische
sünde oder wenn man es schaffe
formulierenden todsünde so etwas zu
machen und vor allem wenn man so eine
vorbildfunktion hat wie von der leyen wo
man so viele menschen jetzt verlangt man
darf nicht vergessen es sind ja unsere
steuergelder und wenn man so damit
umgeht da habe ich echt angst wenn
weitere milliarden und billionen nach
brüssel gehen der so leichtfertig damit
umgeht jetzt hat sie ja wahrscheinlich
selber nicht dieses diesen jet bestellt
sondern ihre mitarbeiter wer ist denn
dafür zuständig eigentlich dass so eine
dienstreise so blöd geplant ist
dass das büro natürlich von der frau von
der leyen aber das ist noch mal wenn ich
wenn ich so hohe anforderungen an die
menschen in europa stelle gerade jetzt
post co wird wo wir alle probleme haben
wieder in gang zu kommen und dann sagt
man wir müssen zu recht nett was tun
gegen die erderwärmung für den
klimaschutz so dann muss das in der
kommission stringenz schon mal passieren
und da muss jeder wissen dass man das
nicht tut und die strecke von wien
schwechat nach bratislava zu fliegen war
hat er auch sicherheitskontrollen man
hat immense kosten der ökologische
fußabdruck ist schlecht und hier geht es
um steuergelder und ökologie und
ökonomie hat das passt überhaupt nicht
und da stimmt etwas in der kommission
nicht wenn man praktisch als mitarbeiter
des so entscheiden kann aber hier hätte
die von der leyen das ist ja nicht der
erste flug den sie machen die mehr ist
die hälfte ihre dienstreisen wenn es
richtig recherchiert ist von den
kollegen aus großbritannien 18 34 hat
sie mir privatflieger gemacht also das
ist jetzt nicht ein ausrutscher es ist
kein ausdruck schon da muss man schon
die kommission auffordern hier als
vorbild für hand zu gehen und dann
fliegt man nicht musst dich economy
fliegen die können business fliegen was
auch immer das ist auf jeden fall
ökonomisch und ökologisch besser als mit
einem privatflieger von nach fahrplan
nun sind sie ja auch in europa zuständig
damit auch viel unterwegs gehen sie dann
immer als vorbild voran
also ich habe mir elektroauto und da
kann ich ihnen in einer anderen sendung
gern mal was dazu sagen zumal erfahrung
und natürlich auch noch normalen
fossilen verbrenner beide distanzen
fliegen wir wenn es nicht anders geht es
natürlich eine frage von derzeit auch
von wie zum beispiel von münchen nach
brüssel wenn sie den zug funktioniert
ist das wunderbar oder wann fliegt das
ist lange distanz aber kurze strecken zu
fliegen also sie werden nicht nicht
erwischen dass ich jetzt wird es auch
bei uns nicht mehr erlaubt sein dass ich
von münchen nach nürnberg und flieger
fliegt das ist aber nicht doppelt so
weit die strecke das wird sicherlich
nicht passieren weil das macht man
einfach nicht das ist auch zeitlich
vollkommener unsinn absoluten sind in
der zeit wo ich am flughafen durch die
sicherheitskontrolle bin bin ich ja
schon bin ich ja dann schon in nürnberg
dadurch etwas also das funktioniert zwar
nicht was sind denn ihre konstruktiven
vorschläge für politiker die sie haben
es gesagt ja zeitlich auch oft eng
getaktet sind und morgens hier und
nachmittags da sein müssen
also erstens
digitalisierung und auch cupic hat uns
eines gezeigt dass man natürlich auch
viele digitale konferenz machen kann da
wo es um normale abstimmung geht wo man
nicht im menschen ins auge sehen muss ja
wo man dinge nicht mit feedback
besprechen muss wo man die reaktion
sehen muss digitale dinge zu machen
sowie das eben auch von den unternehmen
jetzt vorgelebt kriegt wir machen das
auch dem steuerzahlerbund so wir haben
unsere ganzen treffen die wir sonst in
berlin auch haben den deutschen
steuerzahler und komplett
heruntergefahren wir schauen dass wir
uns einmal im jahr noch persönlich
mindestens begegnen weil es schon
wichtig ist aber so weit wie möglich
einfach zu überprüfen pläne zu
überprüfen was kann ich digital waren
und dann aber auch als vorbild
vorangehen ich brauche kein privatjet
ich brauche keinen privaten das kind
linienverbindungen und die sollte man
dann nutzen und das erwartet niemand von
einer kommissionspräsidentin dass sie so
wie wir in der handelt lasse occean
ökonomie sondern dass ihr da wo ich
business trägt aber es ist trotzdem zig
fach billiger für uns ist unser
steuergeld und ich erwarte und es ist
nicht nur die kritik dass eine
aufforderung das mit unserem steuergeld
ordentlich umgegangen wird das ist eine
erwartung die wir haben und wenn sie
diesen vorbildfunktion wahr nimmt dann
ist ja auch glaubwürdiger vielen danke
michael jäger vom europäischen
steuerzahler bund
peter du wirst noch weiterhin bei uns
und real liegt noch was auf der seele
wie ich merke ja weil frau von der leyen
hat nichts wichtiges gemacht also es war
jetzt nicht da das jetzt krisenmanagerin
durch europa reisen musste dass sie
wirklich sachen klären musste sondern
sie hat fördergelder freigegeben sie hat
keine hilfen freigeben sie hat sich also
selbst gesund und da darf man den termin
dann anders machen da war es nochmal
doppelt unnötig was sie da gemacht hat
jetzt hat jeder gesagt es gibt die
möglichkeit digitale konferenzen
zu machen andererseits ist es ja oft so
auch bei diesem gipfel der reisen jetzt
25.000 menschen aus fast 200 ländern an
wo man natürlich auch sagen kann
wahnsinn während beispielsweise wichtige
menschen wie der chinesische und der
russische präsident das digital machen
ist es tatsächlich so wichtig dass man
da zusammensitzt dass man sich spürt
dass man sich in die augen schaut ja das
ist bei großen gipfel veranstaltung ist
das tatsächlich so und gerade wenn es
wirklich darum geht dass um etwas noch
gerungen wird da haben ja vorher
monatelang manchmal jahrelang die ganzen
delegation sachen verhandelt und dann
gibt es sachen die bleiben offen da
können sich die delegation nicht nicht
darauf einigen und das geht manchmal nur
visa vie unter den ist unter den starts
leuten das hat man oft gesehen das ist
nicht nur bei bei friedens oder bei
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen so dass
es auch bei anderen sachen so auch in
koalitionsverhandlungen
koalitionsverhandlungen also statt das
sich 22 arbeitsgruppen treffen und zum
schluss kommen die bosse zusammen dann
werden die offenen fragen geklärt das
geht unter den großkopferten von daher
ganz abschaffen kann man solche
gipfeltreffen nicht sollte man auch
nicht und man sollte auch von allein
nicht komplett das fliegen verbieten sie
hat eigentlich mein eigenen flieger also
und hat der der wichtigste politiker
europas hat keinen eigenen flieger wie
egal die staatschefs aber man muss
gucken wann ist es nötig wenn es unnötig
und wann ist es nur zur quasi einmal um
sich selbst gut darzustellen also zu
seinem idealen selbstbefriedigung und
das wobei von bei war bei frontfrau von
der leyen jetzt tatsächlich mal der fall
es ging wurden sich um sie selber und
das im guten licht dastehen dass die
fördergelder vertragen kann und da
gehört sich so etwas schlicht und
ergreifend überhaupt nicht es ist
problem für politiker n ich sag mal
öffentlichen flugzeugen zu reisen wenn
sie vorher business klasse sitzen tun
sie ja meistens weil sie auch arbeiten
müssen das soll man nicht jetzt
gleichauf oder verteufeln aber viele
menschen gehen daran vorbei es geht auch
um sicherheitskräfte es ist ein problem
müssten die einen privatjet fliegen
müssen sie nicht und viele fliegen auch
manchmal linie also damals man die
bundeskanzlerin vielleicht auch wir
fordern ein kann das ein problem sein
aber dann steigt man halt als letzter
ein und nicht als erster den rennen die
leute auch nicht an einem vorbei
business class ist ein relativ
abgeschlossen also man kann auch linie
fliegen hängt man von der einstufung ab
die man in der sicherheitsklasse hat das
entscheidend oft auch nicht die
politiker selbst sondern manchmal dann
halt die sicherheitskräfte aber jeweils
völlig unnötig aber muss man überhaupt
nicht reden und die so einen popel flug
einmal über die grenze hüpfen schule und
das kann man sogar zu fuß